What's an example of a data visualization that you've seen that
tells a subjective story, rather than an objective one?
>> There's a bunch.
Probably the most well known one that I would fit in that category,
are Nicholas Felton's annual reports.
>> Mm.
>> They're super beautiful.
And, you know, I guess you could argue about their objectivity.
But they're, they're very much personal, extremely personal information.
They're just personal, they're personal annual reports.
So, hard to describe them.
But if you go look at them you'll, you'll see what I mean.
I think in that vein,
there's been a lot more kind of personal data reporting, which is interesting.
He sort of set the standard with these annual reports.
But, there are more and more people doing kind of personal data tracking.
And then doing interesting visual things with that data.
So there's a new project, I'm going to forget the guy's name who made it,
but I think the website is aprilzero.com.
And it's this really, really in-depth sort of personal data reporting platform.
And the interface is really beautiful.
I'm not sure what I can kind of learn from it.
But just aesthetically, it's like quite stunning.
And you can see you know, his, his travel information.
And sort of, how much he's working and what his calendar schedule is.
And I think you see he has, you know, Fitbit, or
whatever these different like, wearable technologies.
And so those pieces of information are reporting in there too.
I think, you know, it's really interesting, this kind of stuff.
because it, it's not, I don't know if that makes it subjective or objective.
But it's, it's very personal.
So in that sense, it's sort of just taking the view of that one,
that one person or that one experience